Chief,
Chief Dive Ala
Something's off, you know, but you can't
put your finger on it.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahuaa mentions
to us a dua that our prophet sallall.aii
wasallam made privately to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
He
he raised his concern
to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in this dua
and Allah
narrates that dua to us and makes it a
fixed verse of the Quran to remind us of
this very important
thing and that is that the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam said as
Allah tells us in surah
and the messenger said the messenger
here is Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and the messenger said oh my
lord indeed my people have taken this
Quran this recitation
as something abandoned notice the
wording he didn't say they have
abandoned abandoned this Quran. That's
what you would expect the wording to be.
He didn't say my people have abandoned
the Quran. No, he said my people
have designated the Quran for
abandonment
as a constant thing. Now obviously
this is regarding the mushik and the
kufur of his people they didn't believe
in him and they designated the Quran as
rejected and they abandoned it now why
did Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala make this
a verse in the Quran to remind the
Muslim of what it's it's we who recite
ite the Quran. We are the ones who re
read this verse and recite it. Why is it
to remind us always
never to abandon the Quran?
Never to abandon the Quran, to turn our
back to the Quran or to turn away from
the Quran or even to walk in front of
the Quran. What does that mean?
So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
refers to the Quran by many references,
many
many descriptions he gives the Quran.
One of the descriptions that Allah gives
it is huda.
It is guidance.
It is not just a guidance. It's not just
the guidance. It is guidance incarnate.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala refers to the
Quran as
it is a guide. Now
what do we imagine a guide is?
I need to go somewhere that I have no
idea how to get there or maybe I have a
general idea but I need someone to guide
me through the specifics
to get me to a certain destination.
So I hire someone or I find someone that
will act as my guide.
This guide has to by default be in front
of me and I follow the guide.
Now what happens if I walk in front of
the guide?
So now the guide is behind me. I've
given my back to the guide.
Is it possible for me to be guided
by a guide that is behind me? No. This
is why the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam gives us this incredible
statement, this incredible analogy. He
says
the Quran
is an interceder
whose intercession is always accepted by
Allah
and it is as well an undefeable
opponent.
Whoever places the Quran in front of
him, the Quran will guide him to
paradise.
And whoever places the Quran behind his
back,
it will drive him to the hellfire.
Listen to to this statement. It's an
incredible
statement of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam with such imagery.
How can a person
who believes in the Quran inadvertently
maybe even unbeknownst to themselves put
the Quran behind them?
Fail to follow the Quran.
This is how it works. This is how it
happens.
A person
comes to a conclusion
and then looks for that conclusion in
the Quran.
This is the recipe, the formula for
damnation.
If a person is
reads the Quran looking for something,
they will find it.
people murder in in the in our history.
Men who memorized the Quran through and
through,
recited it day and night,
have recited it so intensely that even
while they were asleep, their lips were
still moving with its recitation.
And they used that same Quran as an
evidence to kill and murder the
companions of the prophet sallall.aii
Wasam,
the killer of Ali
Ali, the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam's cousin and son-in-law and the
father, the only father of his lasting
of his lasting offspring, the father
of Al Hassan Hussein.
Ali
the great scholar who was with the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam in
every battle
even when he wasn't there physically he
was counted as being there that is how
steadfast ali
was
and ali was the great khalifa
who concluded the 30 years of guidance
and successorship of prophethood
that Ali
came out one day
at the break of dawn. Just before the
break of dawn, before
he came to wake up the people for
a man came out of the shadows and struck
Ali with his sword in his face. He was
trying to hit him in the face and he
caught him in the edge of his head.
and he was then
taken into custody by the other
Muslim
and
they brought this man to see who he was.
They find that it is Abdul Rahman ib
Muljim.
Who is Abdul Rahman ib Muljim? You might
say
Abdul Rahman Mulim is a man that was
hired and designated by Omar
himself al Far
and sent with a delegation to Iraq to
teach the Quran. This is not just any
man.
Can you imagine being qualified in the
eyes of Omarab
and sent on his behalf on behalf of the
great Khalifa al Far to teach an entire
country of people the Quran the words of
Allah that's who Abdahmanb
was ali
told his companions as he lay on his
deathbed for three consecutive days in
agony
because of this incredible injury that
he had sustained which would later prove
fatal.
Ali
tried to reason with his companions
not to kill
Abdman Muljim.
And we will talk about why that is. But
they took Abdul Rahman Muljim
and he was ultimately put to death.
And Abdul Rahman ib Muljim
said, "Cut me limb from limb, piece by
piece,
except for my tongue.
do not interfere with my tongue
because I don't want to be on this earth
for the blink of an eye for a moment
without the ability to remember Allah.
He said this as he was being taken apart
and put to death and ultimately he was
for killing not just any man but
and he died
remembering and praising Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala. Those who were there
witnessed this incredible dichotomy
where you have a man who is killing Ali,
murdering the greatest man of his gener
of his time at that moment
and he is doing it out of service for
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
He said this situation,
this is a disease that has no cure. How
can you address a disease that?
A man who is using the Quran as an
evidence to kill.
Now, here's the question.
What was his fatal mistake? What led
Abdul Rahman Muljim to this end?
The answer, he walked in front of the of
the guide. He wasn't behind the guide.
He was in front of the guide. How was he
in front of the guide? He had
conclusions
prior to reading the Quran.
So when he read the Quran, it said what
he had already concluded in his mind.
That is one story of many
where men and women use the book of
Allah, the Quran throughout history as
an evidence for the most atrocious
and most terrible of crimes and most
heinous of acts. How does this happen?
Because they have a conclusion and then
they look for it in the Quran. Imagine a
detective who comes upon a crime scene
and in his mind he has already
determined that so and so is the
perpetrator.
Everything that he sees in that crime
scene is going to seem to point towards
his already preconceived notion and
conclusion.
And any evidence that disproves that
will be ignored.
This is not a detective.
That's not how we learn.
So when a person approaches the Quran
trying to teach it rather than learn
from it, this person will invariably go
astray.
Even if they have committed the Quran to
memory, even if they recite it day and
night, even if they had passed the
scrutiny of Omarab himself, even if they
were commissioned by Omarab himself,
there is no cure for a person who
believes something before receiving the
evidence. This is precisely
the root of disbelief.
What did the people of Pharaoh say to
Moses?
They said, "Whatever," they said to
Moses, "whatever you show us of miracles
to try and trick us with your magic, no
matter what it is, we will never believe
you." So, they had already decided they
wouldn't believe before they received
the evidence. How could they ever be
benefited by this evidence?
And so this is a way that a person a
Muslim
may abandon the Quran
under the guise and appear to himself
and delude himself that he is following
the Quran when really he has placed it
behind him. So usually we just give
these few minutes to kind of get the
juices flowing. So people if they have
any questions went a little bit extra
today but inshallah we will take any
questions now
if there are any questions. If there are
not any questions then I'll keep
talking.
[Arabic recitation]
So she you mentioned there's a lot of
ways Subhan Allah could walk as you call
it in in front of the Quran and one of
them nowadays you hear a lot of
without the prior knowledge of dean or
even
or Quran they would say I would I think
this way I feel this way you know and if
you ask him for a simple meaning of
the Quran they don't really have any the
tools
or maybe the the sources. So what is a
road map for a the someone who
doesn't have a knowledge of dean to be
guided from Quran and you would give
good advice should we who should we
listen to what books we need to read and
things that if you want to give
a road map for someone who's really
not really knowledgeable in terms of
of of dean in general. Very very good
question and un
unexpectedly or you wouldn't expect that
this question it seems so simple and
straightforward but you'd be surprised
how this question how rarely I am asked
this question and that is how do I start
how do I learn from the Quran how do I
make the Quran a part of my life in a
healthy way and be safe from
misguidance.
I want to start with one thing and that
is
categorizing the meanings of the Quran.
Notice what I'm saying. The meanings
plural of the Quran
Abbas,
the great muess of the companions, the
designated muess of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. He said the Quran
has four types of meanings. Notice this
every verse
these are four categories of meanings.
The first one is a meanings that no
person has an excuse to not know.
Okay. The second type of meanings
is
a meaning of the text of the verse that
the Arabs know from their natural
tongue, from their native tongue. We'll
explain what this means. Number three,
a category of meanings that only the
scholars know.
And number four, a category of meanings
that only Allah knows. These are four.
Memorize them. Put them in your mind in
order to understand how to approach the
Quran. Number one, meanings that
everyone can understand.
When a person reads the Quran in any
language,
in any translation,
any Muslim, Arab, non-Arab reads it in
Arabic, reads it in English, even a
non-Muslim can pick up the text of the
Quran and read it and understand those
meanings zena is haram, alcohol is
haram, water is halal, right? Allah
is one and only. Worship Allah alone
without any partners. Follow the
messengers. Muhammad is the messenger of
Allah, etc., etc. These are meanings
that are evident in any language to any
person who hears or reads the Quran.
Number two are meanings that only a
person proficient in the Arabic language
may see or understand.
And these are meanings regarding the
intricacies and the nuance of the text.
Right? Why the why the words certain
words are chosen? What's the difference
between
what's the difference between
and
what are the differences? These are
things that are reserved for the Arabic
language. Arab linguists and grimarians,
they are the ones who see these
meanings. Okay. Number three are
meanings that only the scholars know.
When we say scholars, we're not talking
about engineers or physicists or medical
doctors. We are speaking about scholars
of the Quran and Sunnah.
They are proficient in the revelation of
Allah.
for instance the statement of Allah
subhanahua
what does this mean? The male and female
thief cut and sever their hands. What's
that mean? The hand in the Arabic
language is all the way to the shoulder.
And which hand is it? right or left. And
here
so it means cut both of their arms off
up until the shoulder. That's what the
Arabic language says. Is that what that
means? No. Only a person who knows the
sunnah of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam is able to understand that
verse as Allah intended.
Right? And the examples of this are
many.
Those who believe and do not mix in
their belief any oppression or
wrongdoing.
Does that mean that those who believe
and never sin? That's what it means in
the Arabic language. But the prophet
explained that wrongdoing here is a shik
meaning those who believe in it. And the
examples of this are many, numerous, all
through the Quran. You will only be able
to understand the Quran as Allah
intended, no matter how proficient in
Arabic a person is, if they are
proficient in the prophet's sai.
That's the third type. The fourth type
is meanings or knowledge that is
reserved for Allah alone. What does that
mean? for instance, the reality of
paradise.
How many descriptions do we get of
paradise in the Quran? Vivid
descriptions. Descriptions so vivid it
makes you feel you are sitting in
paradise in real time. However, Allah
says, "In spite of this, I have prepared
for my righteous servants a place no eye
has ever seen the likes of, no ear has
ever heard the likes of, and has never
crossed the mind or imagination of any
human being." So no matter how much we
imagine, we have never imagined the
reality of paradise. Allah tells us that
he is the one who is above.
He rose above his throne. We know what
that means in the Arabic language. It
doesn't have more than one meaning.
But how did he rise above his throne?
This is something that is unfathomable
to the human being. Even if it were
explained, we could never understand
such such a thing.
Allah sees everything. How does Allah
see everything? Only Allah knows that.
That is a meaning that is reserved for
Allah. So these are four types of
meanings in every verse
in every chapter of the Quran.
One that is apparent to everyone. One
that is only picked up by linguists. One
that is only known to those proficient
those scholars of Islam. and one
reserved a meaning that is reserved only
for Allah. Every single verse. Now back
to the question which was how does a
person read the Quran and maintain being
guided by the Quran and not stepping in
front of it? If a person wishes to read
the Quran, whether in Arabic or English,
and is not a scholar, a student of
knowledge, the everyday Muslim, which
one of those four meanings are they
going to learn every time they read the
Quran?
Which one?
[Arabic recitation]
the second and third. This is what
scholars are for.
You go and you spend years of your life
and dedicate yourself entirely to
learning ancient Arabic in order to be
able to understand those things. You go
and dedicate years of your life and
travel and leave where you're from and
put yourself in discomfort and possibly
poverty in order to learn the sunnah of
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam.
There's no other way.
And so when you go to read the Quran,
that is the meaning you are looking for.
The meaning that is apparent to
everyone. a person who is an Arab, they
speak Arabic, they pick up the Quran and
they take the
you know there is a u there is a hash
which is
printed in most
by
you read the meanings of those words
that you don't know and you read the
Quran every single single day. You do
not allow yourself to get confused with
the
right. What do I mean by confused with
the you go to open the Quran? You see,
what does that mean?
Let me look in
let me look in and then you find inbin
25 different opinions and and and 20
different narrations etc. Let me look in
let me look in
places that men have to men have to
study for decades in order to be able to
in order to be able to sail those
waters. Those are not just for
everybody, right? And so you start
getting confused by all these things and
you still haven't passed al this is not
a way to learn the Quran. The Quran
speaks for itself. You open the Quran,
you know what each word means and you
read it every single day. You read a
portion as if you have never heard the
verse before
and it will change your life.
It is a light that will change your
life. It will penetrate to the deepest
parts of your heart and it will
enlighten your mind if you allow it to.
But if you are stubborn and insist on
the Quran saying what you already know,
you'll never learn anything.
Number number two, if a person is a
non-Arab, they don't speak the Arabic
language. They take a translation like
Sahib International. I have read dozens
if not more than dozens of translations
of the Quran. I've worked with them for
many years. The best one that I have
seen is Sah International. It's very
concise, written in modern English, very
easy to understand. It's eloquently
written, right? You take this
translation which is essentially a and
you read it every single day. you want
to know more
then you take a book on the prophet
like
or
when the moon split by
in Arabic or English now you have a
context for this Quran this book
okay sheh I want to learn more than that
you take a book like
or a book the a bridged
and you read it as well a portion of it
every day you do the Quran sheh I
want more details than that now you have
to travel
now you're speaking about becoming a
student of knowledge and you can't do
that sitting down in the air
conditioning feet up drinking sipping
your lemonade and not being
uncomfortable the Quran Our Mashiah used
to tell us the Quran and knowledge in
general and it is a statement that is
Zari said many many centuries ago. He
said if you give it all of yourself
it will give you some of itself
and if you give it some of yourself it
will give you none of itself.
It is not something that you will learn
through an electronic device.
Not serious knowledge. You will not
learn it on YouTube. You will not learn
it on FaceTime. You will not learn it on
Facebook. If you want to learn the
religion of Allah and the inheritance of
Muhammad sallall.aii alaihi wasallam you
have to be prepared to sacrifice
Omar said
Omar said tell the student of knowledge
to put on a pair of iron shoes for his
path cuz his path is long and
unfortunately knowledge has become we
are consumers we live we live in a
disposable
day don't We This is the era of the
disposable.
This is the epic of the dispos
Disposable silverware, disposable
appliances.
You find a job, you find another with
slightly better perks. You move over.
You're just a number amongst numbers,
right? Disposable everything. Personal
everything. You don't your car.
It's got a scratch, don't worry about
repairing it. Just trade it in for a new
one. Right? If you want a new car, you
just go get a new one. You don't work on
the one that you have. If you want some
clothes, you don't patch your clothes up
anymore. You don't take it to a
seamstress or put a patch in it anymore
unless you want it to look stylish.
Otherwise, just buy buy new pants, buy
new shirts. There's people that don't
even wash their clothes. They just wear
them and buy new clothes every single
month. We live in the era of the
disposable. And so now as consumers,
we've been taught this through years of
brainwashing. We start to do this with
human beings, with each other. I don't
my husband. I want a new one. I
don't my wife. I want a new one. I
can get a new one. I don't my imam.
Let's get a new one. And so we start to
I don't this teacher. I want to get
a new one. And we think that knowledge
is the same. It is not. The
the
students of hadith they would give
every day before they went to see their
and make dua. Oh Allah conceal his
faults from us.
It's so
they would go to a to study
and every day before they go to see him
they would give charity and make dua
that Allah conceal his faults why they
don't want to shan to get a foothold in
them to turn them from knowledge
and mash used to do something similar
with their students there were some
scholars of the
that were known to be very very harsh
with their students when new students
would come
in order to drive away the emotional and
the weak so that only the strongest
remain. Who did this? Didn't
do this?
Remember the story of Jalut and Talut?
Jal did
that
he came across a river
and he said just before they went into
battle, "Whoever drinks from this river
is not in my mil in my army." It was
said he had four 4,000. It started as
80,000.
It went down to 4,000. He said, "Whoever
drinks from this river is not of me. And
whoever does not drink from it can
continue with me to the front lines."
And he made an exception for one hand of
water.
Right? So we have the best, the good,
and the rejected.
And so the companions mention Ib Abbass
mentions
and others of the companions and Sah
Bkari that of 4,000
every one of them drank except for 315
or so the exact amount of companions who
were with the prophet in the battle of
B.
And they are the ones who continued to
battle. He sent everyone back. I don't
want you.
Why? This doesn't make sense. Explain it
to us. This is your leader. You listen
or you don't. And these were the men
that continued to battle and defeated
the great jalut and
became the king of ban after this event.
And so the point here is that this is
what seeking knowledge is. It's not what
a lot of us imagine. It's not going
to Yale or Harvard where you have to get
your projects ready and take your laptop
and you have to, you know, go to these
fancy places and sit down and you have a
counselor and you have no you're on your
own. You want to study, you could spend
20 years and never earn your sheh's
respect or never earn his his
recommendation, etc. The point is is
that knowledge is a different thing for
the everyday Muslim. You stick with the
Quran the a book of and a book of hadith
that is concise. That is more than
enough for you to contemplate the Quran
every day
and
All
[Silence]
for
Allah.
[Silence]
Apologies for the way that our question
and answer went today. Inshallah, next
week there will be no intro. We will
just go straight into the questions.
[Arabic recitation]
try to make up Low thing.